Let's go next to our caller from the three
47 area code.
Who's calling today from three four seven.
Oh, it was the snake.
Yes it is.
Who's this?
Okay,
this is Alex from Brooklyn, New York.
Hey Alex, what's up?
So I had two things on my mind.
One is sort of my opinion.
One I wanted to ask for yours.
And they're both, uh, an opinion [inaudible]
uh, they're both related to impeachment rather
than Iran.
Sure.
[inaudible]
so the first thing I wanted to talk about
was this like idea from Democrats sort of
like this, you know, examination of this impeachment
that um, you know, as this thing will progress
and maybe afterwards, no Americans will kind
of look back on this and think, Oh my goodness,
how could we support Trump?
Like what is going on?
Like we fell to this ideology and, um, just
sort of, um, fear-mongering that led us to
vote for Trump when in reality, in my opinion,
we're going to have something more along the
lines of how people look at the civil war
in the sense of that there's still a population
in this country that still thinks that the
civil war was, you know, Northern digression
or it's about, you know, disruption of state
rights and whatnot.
That's interesting.
So if I understand correctly, what you're
saying is no matter what happens during the
Trump administration with Iran or with anything
else, eventually there will be people who
will see Trump as this great hero.
Much like you still have people who see the
civil war as being about States' rights rather
than about slavery or whatever.
Like there will always be a contingent that
sees it that way.
Yes.
When I see like kids that Trump rallies, you
know, sharing them on, I feel like many years
from now they'll tell their kids Trump with
the greatest president ever.
Uh, whether it's, you know, ends in 10 months
or four and a half years, but [inaudible]
I don't think it wrong.
I think maybe you're overstating the importance
that Trump is going to have historically.
I mean, I hope so.
I hope that historically Trump will be seen
as, as an aberration, but that people won't
talk about him that much one way or the other
much the same way that a lot of presidents
aren't really discussed very much today.
But the more erratic has behavior of course
the more likely that he does remain a topic
of conversation.
But it's an interesting point of view for
sure.
The idea that there's always going to be at
the same time though, you know, if you think
back to like William Howard Taft, is there
a contingent that goes around idolizing Taft
today?
He just kind of become, not, not, not a big
factor.
Maybe Trump would be the same, although certainly
he, he would, uh, ideally be seen as an aberration
no matter how long it goes.
I hope as well.
Yeah.
And the second point that I want to bring
up actually does relate to the impeachment
trials, but it also has something to do with
Iran.
So I was watching one of your videos, um,
about Techron Carlson talking about how, you
know, we shouldn't be in this war with Iran,
like so on and so forth.
And he mentioned John Bolton as a non genius
and you know, to a certain point, I agree
with them on that.
Yeah.
But in his commentary, he sort of, you know,
dismisses John Bolton and I was wondering
if you think he might be playing this sort
of like side role of dismissing John Bolton
because in the case that he does somehow end
up testifying in the Senate, although with
[inaudible]
yeah,
we can play off as you know, this guy, he's
a warmonger and you know, even though he,
I don't believe he had anything to, he had
anything to do with Iran, he on the other
hand could be dismissed as just another warmonger
and his testimony is worth little to nothing.
I don't think that that's Tucker's motivation,
if anything, uh, it, it's just that Tucker
has always had disagreements with John Bolton
because John volt Bolton is very interventionist
and Tucker Carlson has an anti interventionist
streak.
I don't think it's nearly as calculated as,
as you're suggesting.
Uh, Alex, thank you so much.
Great to hear from you.
I do have to move on to other callers and
I hope to hear from you again.